This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1999, a nature documentary about wolves, called wolves, came out in IMAX theaters. This alpha female is searching for a den site. It isn't merely a personal choice, or her decision will determine the disposition of the path. The film documents the reintroduction of wolves across the Western United States. That's producer Emmett Fitzgerald. And it has everything you want in a nature documentary. Sweeping landscapes, a narrator with a rugged yet soothing voice.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1999 年，一部名为《狼》的关于狼的自然纪录片在 IMAX 影院上映。这只头狼正在寻找巢穴。这绝不仅仅是她个人的选择，她的决定将决定这条路径的走向。这部片子记录了狼被重新引入美国西部各州的过程。那是制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。它具备了你对自然纪录片的所有期待。壮丽的风景，一位声音粗犷而又抚慰人心的旁白。
A potential prey. And best of all, wolf puppies. The film was designed to combat the misinformation campaigns of the launching and hunting lobbies, which portray wolves typically as vicious killers fit only for elimination. That's Chris Palmer, one of the film's producers. He and his team wanted to rehabilitate the wolf's image by showcasing the relationships within a pack. Rather than just a bunch of scenes of wolves ripping caribou de shreds, they wanted to
潜在的猎物。最棒的是，狼崽。这部电影旨在打击发起者和狩猎游说团体的虚假信息活动，他们通常将狼描绘成只适合被消灭的残忍杀手。那是克里斯·帕尔默，该片的制作人之一。他和他的团队希望通过展示狼群内部的关系来恢复狼的形象。他们想要的不仅仅是一堆狼把驯鹿撕成碎片的场景，而是
show the animals working together to raise a litter of pups. Our goal was to show closeups of a wolf pack interacting in complex subtle ways. But filming the intimate lines of Wild Wolves is virtually impossible because they do not tolerate the presence of people. Still they filmed inside a wolf's den and in the finished movie viewers are led into this private moment as wolf pups cozy up against their wolf's den. And in the finished movie, viewers are led into this private moment as wolf pups cozy up against their mother's belly. Because newborn pups have no way
展示这些动物齐心协力抚养一窝幼崽。我们的目标是展示狼群以复杂微妙的方式互动的特写镜头。但是拍摄野生狼的私密生活几乎是不可能的，因为它们不容忍人类的存在。尽管如此，他们在狼窝里进行了拍摄，在成片中，观众被引领进入这个私密的时刻，小狼崽依偎在狼妈妈的肚子旁。在成片中，观众被引领进入这个私密的时刻，小狼崽依偎在狼妈妈的肚皮上。因为刚出生的幼崽没有办法
to regulate their own temperature. Their mother's body heat is the only thing that keeps them warm. When the film came out, Palmer went to some screenings where audience members could ask questions. And after one screening, someone in the audience asked me, how did you film the amazing shot of the mother wolf in its den?
调节自身的体温。母亲的体温是唯一能让他们保持温暖的东西。电影上映时，帕尔默参加了一些观众可以提问的放映会。在一次放映结束后，台下一名观众问我：“你是怎么拍到母狼在窝里的精彩特写的？”
Palmer's heart sank. Because the truth about that intimate scene in the wolf den wasn't pretty. Come here ears and a simpleist nurse. We rented captive wolves. We rented captive wolves. We rented captive wolves. The shots of the puppies in the den were not filmed in the wild. Instead, the film crew had gone to a game farm where the wolves were more used to humans
帕尔默的心沉了下去。因为狼窝里那个私密场景的真相并不美妙。过来耳朵和一个简单的护士。我们租了圈养的狼。我们租了圈养的狼。我们租了圈养的狼。窝里小狗的镜头不是在野外拍摄的。相反，摄制组去了一个对人类更习惯的狼群所在的野生动物农场，
and built an artificial den with cameras inside. I was suddenly staring, starkly, at an ethical dilemma for myself. Did I tell the truth and answer truthfully, therefore betraying our trade secrets and filmmaking, or did I continue to lie and pretend that the captive wolves were, in fact, were wild when they weren't? Palmer decided to come clean. And when I did this, I could feel the
并在里面建了一个带摄像头的 人工巢穴。我突然面临着一个严峻的道德困境。我是该说实话、如实回答，从而背叛我们的行业机密和电影制作，还是继续撒谎，假装圈养的狼其实是野生的？帕尔默决定坦白。当我这样做时，我能感受到
audience's disappointment. And this moment was a bit of a turning point for him. Up to that point, I think I kind of have a scene where why would they care? But they do care. People do care. When people watch documentaries, especially science-based documentaries, they are assuming they are seeing the truth. They are seeing things that are authentic and genuine and truthful. And when they find out that is not the case, they get very upset. Of course, there's some level of illusion
观众的失望。这一刻对他来说是一个转折点。在那之前，我想我有一种“他们为什么会在乎”的心态。但他们确实在乎。人们确实在乎。当人们观看纪录片，尤其是以科学为基础的纪录片时，他们默认自己看到的是真相。他们看到的是真实、地道和真实的东西。当他们发现事实并非如此时，他们会非常沮丧。当然，所有电影制作中都有某种程度的幻觉。
in all filmmaking. You're editing footage to form a narrative. Psst, we do this in radio too. But illusions in nature documentaries exist on a spectrum. In some cases, these illusions help tell the truth about animals. But in others, not so much. On the far end of that truth spectrum, you know, over toward the straight up false end,
你在剪辑素材以形成叙事。嘘，我们在广播里也这么做。但自然纪录片中的虚幻是存在于一个光谱上的。在某些情况下，这些虚幻有助于讲述关于动物的真相。但在其他情况下，则未必如此。在这个真相光谱的另一端，你知道的，也就是彻头彻尾虚假的这一端，
is a film called White Wilderness. I still remember watching White Wilderness as a child when I was about 11 years old. It was a documentary produced by Disney in 1958 about the high Arctic. In this land of many mysteries, it's a strange fact that the largest legends seem to collect around the smallest creatures. One of these is a nasty little rodent called the lemming. In one scene, a herd of tiny lemmings approaches a rocky cliff along the ocean. They reach the final precipice. This is the last chance to turn back.
有一部电影叫《白色荒野》。我还依稀记得大约 11 岁时作为一个孩子观看《白色荒野》的情景。那是迪士尼于 1958 年制作的一部关于高纬度北极地区的纪录片。在这个充满神秘的土地上，一个奇怪的事实是，最大的传奇似乎总是围绕着最小的生物。其中之一就是一种讨厌的小啮齿动物，叫做旅鼠。在一个场景中，一群小旅鼠走近了海边的一处岩石悬崖。它们到达了最后的绝壁。这是回头的最后机会。
The little fur balls peer over the edge, and then... They get over they go, casting themselves bodily out into space. They hurl themselves off the cliff and into the water below. The narrator tells us that most have survived the plunge, but then they begin to swim towards the horizon. It's dramatic stuff, except this entire sequence was staged. The producers went to the Arctic, bagged up a bunch of lemmings, and flew them to this cliff along a river in Alberta.
这些小毛球从边缘望过去，然后……它们冲了过去，将自己的身体抛向空中。它们把自己从悬崖上抛向下方冰冷的水中。旁白告诉我们，大多数都在跳水后生还了，但随后它们开始向地平线游去。这是戏剧性的场景，除了整个序列都是摆拍的。制作人们去到北极，抓了一群旅鼠，把它们空运到艾伯塔省一条河流旁边的这个悬崖。
And they put them on a turntable that you don't see in the film, and they threw them off the cliff side into the water and filmed it. And Lemmings don't actually hurl themselves off cliffs. Some Lemmings species do experience traumatic fluctuations in population size, leading to some creative 19th century hypotheses about what might be going on. But the idea of a mass Lemmings suicide ritual is entirely apocryphal. of a mass-lemming suicide ritual is entirely apocryphal. White wilderness didn't invent the lemming suicide myth, but it certainly helped to spread it. The film was seen by millions of people. It even won the Oscar for Best Documentary. Everybody has learned that from that film and been mess led by it. So what we put in these
他们把它们放在电影中看不到的转盘上，把它们从悬崖边扔进水里并拍摄了下来。旅鼠实际上并不会把自己从悬崖上扔下去。某些旅鼠物种确实会经历剧烈的种群规模波动，这导致了一些关于可能发生了什么的 19 世纪的创造性假设。但大规模旅鼠自杀仪式的想法完全是杜撰的。大规模旅鼠自杀仪式的想法完全是杜撰的。《白色荒野》并没有发明旅鼠自杀的神话，但它确实推动了它的传播。这部电影被数百万人观看。它甚至赢得了奥斯卡最佳纪录片奖。每个人都从那部电影中了解到了这一点，并被它误导了。所以我们放进这些
films is importance, and that means they is so important that they are made not only entertainingly, but made accurately and ethically, because they do have an impact. The Lemming scene is an especially egregious example of dishonest filmmaking, but smaller acts of deception happen all the time. And after his experience with the Wolf documentary, Chris Palmer started looking into this stuff.
电影中的内容很重要，这意味着它们非常重要，制作出来不仅要具有娱乐性，还要准确和合乎道德，因为它们确实会产生影响。旅鼠的场景是一个极其恶劣的不诚实电影制作例子，但较小的欺骗行为一直在发生。在经历过狼纪录片的经历后，克里斯·帕尔默开始调查这些事情。
He found filmmakers learning sharks closer to the camera by dumping buckets of fish guts into the ocean and a producer using CGI to edit a sea otter into a shot. Palmer is particularly bothered by filmmakers that harass animals to try to get them to do something exciting. He thinks all this happens because of a race for ratings. And when you focus so much on race like that, you inevitably move towards programs that
他发现电影制作人通过向海洋中倾倒几桶鱼内脏来将鲨鱼吸引到离镜头更近的地方，还有制作人用 CGI 将一只海獭编辑到一个镜头中。帕尔默对那些骚扰动物以试图让它们做出激动人心的举动的电影制作人格外反感。他认为这一切的发生都是因为对收视率的追逐。当你如此专注于这种收视率时，你不可避免地会转向那些
are highly sensational and overly dramatic. A lot of Palmer's criticisms have to do with the visual side of filmmaking, but any conversation about the accuracy of nature documentaries inevitably ends up on the topic of sound. That's because in most wildlife films, the sounds you hear were not recorded while the cameras were rolling. Which makes sense if you think about how different the two technologies are. Most filmmakers use really long telephoto lenses to film animals from a safe distance. But there's no sonic equivalent of a zoom lens.
高度耸人听闻和过于戏剧化的节目。帕尔默的许多批评都与电影制作的视觉方面有关，但任何关于自然纪录片准确性的讨论最终都会落脚于声音这个话题。这是因为在大多数野生动物电影中，你听到的声音并不是在摄像机滚动时录制的。如果你想想这两种技术有多么不同，这是有道理的。大多数电影制作人都使用非常长的长焦镜头来在安全距离外拍摄动物。但变焦镜头并没有声音上的对应物。
For good audio, you need to get a microphone really close to the source of the sound, which can be difficult or dangerous to try and pull off while the cameras are rolling. You can't just walk up to a lion and clipple a pelmike on its mane. And so many of the subtle movement sounds, a chimpanzee rustling through leaves or a hippo squelching in the muck, they don't come from animals at all. They're made by fully artists. So a folios is to basically perform all that movement sound or a film essentially. This is Richard Hinton. Yeah, I sit in this wind-elless room,
为了获得好的音频，你需要让麦克风非常接近声音来源，而在摄像机滚动时尝试做到这一点可能既困难又危险。你不能直接走到狮子跟前，在它的鬃毛上夹一个小型麦克风。因此，许多微妙的动作声音，比如黑猩猩穿过树叶沙沙作响的声音，或者河马在泥地里发出的啧啧声，根本不是由动物发出的。它们是由拟音师（Foley artists）制作的。所以拟音基本上就是为电影表演所有的动作声音。这是理查德·欣顿（Richard Hinton）。是的，我坐在没有风的房间里，
watching it to television, making weird sounds for animals. Hinton performs in a studio with trap doors in the floor. And underneath the floor, you have six pits, each filled with the different material. He says, fully artist spends so much time playing around in these pits that they call each other pit monkeys. There's one gravel, one's filled with sand, one's full of dirt, one's kind of dirt and grass,
看着电视，为动物发出奇怪的声音。欣顿在一个地板上有活动门的录音室里表演。在楼梯地板下面，你有六个坑，每个坑都装满不同的材料。他说，拟音师花大量时间在这些坑里玩耍，以至于他们互相称对方为“坑猴”。一个是砾石，一个是沙子，一个是泥土，一个是泥土和草的混合物，
and then one's a solid stone slab. Each pit is miked up for high quality sound. Hinton watches a silent version of the scene on an HD screen, and he tries to match the movement of the animals. Usually I'm sat on the floor, cross-legged, and I'm kind of lent over the pit, so I can control my weight and the amount of weight that I'm putting into the movement. He starts with the feet. As the animals move, he tries to match their footfalls with his hands.
然后一个是坚固的石板。每个坑都配备了高质量的麦克风。欣顿在高清屏幕上观看该场景的无声版本，并试图配合动物的动作。通常我盘腿坐在地板上，身体前倾在坑上方，这样我可以控制我的体重以及我施加在动作上的重量。他从脚部开始。随着动物的移动，他试着用手去配合它们的脚步。
When you're following animals, you usually use your hands rather than your feet because you have more control. If it's hooves, I'll, you know, I'll use the tips of my fingers and I'll really drive them into the surface so you get that hard attack. If it's something like a lion, then I'll use the flash of my fingers and you get a more paddy, you know, kind of stealthy, kind of stalking, kind of weight to it. Hinton has been doing fully for years and has worked on many big nature documentaries, including Planet Earth 2. With all that practice, he says he can often get it right in just a single take. With all that practice, he says he can often get it right in just a single take. I've been doing it long enough now to know, you know, that point at which a cheater's
当你追踪动物时，你通常用手而不是脚，因为你有更多的控制力。如果是蹄子，你知道的，我会用手指尖，然后把它们狠狠地砸进表面，这样你就能得到那种强烈的撞击感。如果是像狮子这样的动物，那么我会用手指的肉垫，你会得到一种更有肉感的，你知道的，那种鬼鬼祟祟的、潜行的、有重量感的声音。欣顿从事拟音工作多年，参与过许多大型自然纪录片，包括《地球脉动 2》。凭借所有的这些练习，他说他通常只需一遍就能搞定。凭借所有的这些练习，他说他通常只需一遍就能搞定。我干这行够久了，我知道猎豹准备
about to go from a stalk to a sprint because of its shoulder movement and the just the way it pins its ears back. And, you know, the more of this stuff that you do, you start picking up on these little visual clues that all wildlife gives you in terms of what it's about to do with its behavior. So many wildlife films focus on the exact same cast of marquee species, like elephants, leopards, crocodiles, that hadn't rarely comes across footage of an animal he's never fully before. When you first come across something you haven't done, you do spend a couple of minutes just watching the footage through, seeing, right, okay, well, how is this thing moving? How, you know, what's its
从潜行转为冲刺的那一刻，因为它的肩膀运动以及它向后贴耳朵的方式。你知道，你做这种事情越多，你就越开始注意到这些野生动物在它们即将做出某种行为时发出的微小视觉线索。许多野生动物电影都专注于完全相同的那些大牌明星物种，比如大象、豹子、鳄鱼，以至于他很少能遇到他从未做过拟音的动物的镜头。当你第一次遇到你没做过的事情时，你确实会花几分钟把素材看完，看看，对，好吧，这东西是怎么移动的？怎么，你知道的，它的节奏是怎样的？
rhythm? How's it where it shoulders working in relationship to its feet? For more complicated sounds, Hinton has a giant storage area full of materials he's hoarded over the years. Sheets of metal, pieces of rubber, different types of rope. We've got a couple of old wet suits. He takes out a couple of items to demonstrate. In front of me right now, I have some backwings, which was actually just a pair of old gloves. Interestingly, if you use the finger tips,
它的肩膀与脚的关系是如何运作的？对于更复杂的 pentru 声音，欣顿有一个巨大的储藏区，里面装满了多年来他囤积的材料。金属板、橡胶块、不同类型的绳子。我们有一两件旧潜水服。他拿出了几件物品来演示。此刻在我面前，有一些蝙蝠翅膀，实际上只是一副旧手套。有趣的是，如果你用手指尖，
you get backwings. If you flip them over and use the bit you put your hand in, you get back wings. If you flip them over and use the bit you put your hand in, you get pigeon wings. To mimic the sound of an animal walking on snow, Hinton uses a bag of dried custard. When he squeezes the bag, you get that fresh snow crunch. Sometimes he brings in natural materials from the outdoors. The studio has a big garden and in the summer, Hinton will harvest different plants to use in his recordings. The winter, though, can be more challenging. What we'll quite often do is we'll use some old tape. Here I have a combination of some old quarter inch tape, some old VHS tape, it's
你就能得到蝙蝠翅膀。如果你把它们翻过来，用你放手的那一部分，你就会得到蝙蝠翅膀。如果你把它们翻过来，用你放手的那一部分，你就会得到鸽子翅膀。为了模仿动物在雪地上行走的声音，欣顿用了一袋干蛋奶冻。当他挤压这个袋子时，你就会得到那种新鲜雪被踩碎的嘎吱声。有时他会从户外带回天然材料。录音室里有一个大花园，夏天时，欣顿会收割不同的植物来用于他的录音。不过，冬天可能会更有挑战性。我们经常做的是用一些旧磁带。这里我有一些旧的四分之一英寸磁带、一些旧 VHS 磁带的组合，这对于树冠层的效果相当不错。
quite good for kind of leaf canopy work. For example if you have something like a baboon or a chimp and they're clashing about in a tree top. Fully artists share techniques with each other, and some tricks have become so ubiquitous that they've actually changed our understanding of the way nature sounds. I mean, this is the thing. We've been doing phony on that history for so long. What people actually are used to listening to is how we phony stuff, which is kind of weird, so people expect what we do rather than what nature might actually do in real life. For example, elephant feet.
例如，如果你有什么东西，比如狒狒或黑猩猩，它们在树顶上闹腾。拟音师互相分享技术，一些技巧变得如此普遍，以至于它们实际上改变了我们对大自然声音的理解。我的意思是，事情就是这样。我们在历史上做拟音太久了。人们实际习惯听的是我们如何做拟音，这有点奇怪，所以人们期待的是我们所做的，而不是大自然在现实中可能发出的声音。例如，大象的脚。
We expect to hear a big booming sound when a massive elephant foot hits the ground. But that's not what elephants actually sound like. If ever you talk to anybody that works around elephants, they will tell you that elephants make pretty much no sound at all when they walk, because the bottom sort of like section of their foot is just one big fatty cushion. So they're incredibly efficient at distributing their weight as they walk. But Hinton says that if you had no sound at all, it would just feel weird. It's very uncomfortable to see a foot, the size of an elephant, fill a screen and hit
当一头巨大的大象的脚落地时，我们期待听到一个巨大的轰鸣声。但大象实际发出的声音并不是这样的。如果你和任何在象群周围工作的人交谈，他们会告诉你，大象走路时几乎没有发出任何声音，因为它们脚底的那个部位只是一大块脂肪垫。因此，它们在行走时在分散体重方面非常高效。但欣顿说，如果你完全没有声音，那会感觉很奇怪。看到一只大象大小的脚占满屏幕并击中
floor and not hear a sound for it. Hinton tries to find a middle ground between accuracy and giving people the sound they expect. But he says the main goal of Foley is just to provide a little bit of that movement sound needed to help the film flow. Movement sounds are one thing, but then there's the distinctive vocal sounds that an animal makes. You know, a lion's roar or a cuckoo bird's cuckoo.
地面却听不到一点声音，这会让人感到非常不舒服。欣顿试图在准确性和给人们提供他们所期望的声音之间找到一个中间立场。但他说拟音的主要目标只是提供一点帮助电影流畅进行所需的动作声音。动作声音是一回事，然后还有动物发出的独特发声。你知道，狮子的吼声或布谷鸟的布谷声。
Anything that you would term as a vocalization, I growl, the grunt, scream, a roar, a bird call, it's all gonna be as real as we can get it. But just because it's accurate doesn't mean that you're hearing the exact same individual animal that you're seeing on the screen. Unless you can see David Attenborough kneeling next to an orangutan, chances are the sounds that orangutan is making come from a different orangutan altogether. Many sound studios have massive carefully cataloged libraries of animal recordings that sound editors will use to match the specific behavior seen on screen.
任何你可以称之为发声的东西——咆哮、呼噜声、尖叫、吼叫、鸟鸣，都会尽可能地真实。但这并不意味着你听到的正是你在屏幕上看到的个别动物。除非你能看到大卫·爱登堡跪在一只红毛猩猩旁边，否则那只红毛猩猩发出的声音很可能完全来自另一只红毛猩猩。许多录音室都有庞大且仔细分类的动物录音库，声音剪辑师会使用这些录音库来匹配屏幕上看到的特定行为。
And sometimes filmmakers will hire sound recordists to go out and find sounds to fit their film. Recordists like Chris Watson. My name is Chris Watson and I'm a sound recordist. Watson usually gets a storyboard from the filmmakers, and it's his job to go and find sounds that match different scenes. If he's working on a lion sequence, Watson will find a pride he wants to record
有时，电影制作人会雇佣录音师去寻找适合他们电影的声音。像克里斯·沃森这样的录音师。我叫克里斯·沃森，是一名录音师。沃森通常会从电影制作人那里拿到故事板，他的工作就是去寻找与不同场景相匹配的声音。如果他正在制作一个狮子的序列，沃森会找到他想要记录的狮群，
and carefully study their movements. And then realizing, you know, when they're off hunting or when they've gone to another location, you then go and rig your microphones close by where you saw them. They use very long cables and I conceal or disguise microphones near the source of the sound. Then Watson climbs into a hiding place, a safe distance away and waits. It might take you two days, but then eventually that pride, three or four females and nine, ten,
并仔细研究它们的行为。然后意识到，你知道的，当它们去狩猎或去了另一个地方时，你就可以去把你听到的声音附近的麦克风藏好。他们使用非常长的电缆，我在声音来源附近隐藏或伪装麦克风。然后沃森爬到一个安全的隐蔽处，保持一段距离并等待。这可能需要两天时间，但最终那个狮群——三四只雌狮和九只、十只
or dozen cubs will come back to that place and just lay down right in front of your microphones and start vocalizing. Watson takes big predators like these very seriously and he has all kinds of techniques for getting close-up sound without getting too close. He wants to used a really long boom to get his microphone near a cheetah resting beneath a tree. And I, over about an hour, very slowly lowered the boom down to within about three feet of this animal's head. And then I recorded this remarkable close-up, purring sound, which wasn't even audible
甚至一打幼崽会回到那个地方，直接躺在你的麦克风前面并开始发声。沃森非常重视像这样的大型掠食者，他拥有各种各样的技术来获得近距离的声音而又不会靠得太近。他曾使用一个非常长的挑杆，把麦克风靠近一只在树下休息的猎豹。大约一个小时里，我非常缓慢地把挑杆降到离这只动物头部大约三英尺的地方。然后我录下了这个非凡的、近距离的呼噜声，这甚至在我们呆的 10-12 码远的地方都听不见。
where we were 10-12 yards away. Watson also records lots of ambient sounds, and then he sends it all to the editors who carefully piece together an accurate soundscape. In the final product, it looks like the vocalizations are coming from the animals on screen. When he can, though, Watson does try to record sound while the cameras are rolling. Synchronous sound is not impossible, he says, and it can bring a special kind of realism to the film. In the BBC documentary The Life of Birds, the director asked him to mic up a bunch of trees and bushes where he knew songbirds like the sing at dawn, and it worked. The bird showed up right on cue and sang right into his tiny microphones as they filmed.
沃森还录制了大量的环境声音，然后他把所有这些都发给剪辑师，由他们仔细拼凑出一个准确的声音景观。在最终的产品中，发声看起来就像是来自屏幕上的动物。不过，当有可能时，沃森确实会尝试在摄像机滚动时录制声音。同步声音并非不可能，他说，它可以给电影带来一种特殊的现实感。在 BBC 纪录片《鸟类的世界》中，导演让他把一堆树木和灌木丛用麦克风连接起来，他知道鸣禽喜欢在那里迎接黎明唱歌，结果成功了。鸟儿如期出现，并在拍摄时直接对着他微小的麦克风歌唱。
In the early morning light you can see the birds, breath as they exhale from the song. Recording synchronous sound is much easier with bluebirds than say polar bears, but Watson wishes it happened more. He says that in general producers prioritize sites above sounds. They'll spend millions of dollars sending camera people all over the world to get that special shot. And then just worry about finding the right sound later on. Sometimes though, recording the sound separately can actually enhance the accuracy of the soundtrack. In the BBC documentary Life in the Undergrowth, the filmmakers wanted to showcase this bizarre behavior of the Alcon Blue Butterfly caterpillar. Would ants mistake these caterpillars for their own larvae and carry them underground to the ant colony?
在清晨的光线中，你可以看到鸟儿在唱歌时呼出的气息。录制同步声音对于蓝知更鸟来说比北极熊要容易得多，但沃森希望这种情况能发生得更多。他说，总的来说，制作人把视觉置于声音之上。他们会花数百万美元派摄像师去世界各地捕捉那个特殊的镜头。然后才担心稍后找到合适的声音。不过，有时分别录制声音实际上可以提高音轨的准确性。在 BBC 纪录片《地下世界的生活》中，电影制作人想要展示大蓝蝶毛虫这种奇怪的行为。蚂蚁会把这些毛虫误认为是它们自己的幼虫并将它们带到地下蚁群中吗？
Once inside, the caterpillars do something remarkable. They stimulate an internal organ, thinking it's about 300 hers. I had to look up Strygillate too. It means to make a shrill sound by rubbing the legs, wings, or other parts of the body together. In this case, it's the caterpillar's attempt to mimic a hungry baby ant. This sound stimulates the ants to feed the caterpillar. So it's cross species communication, which is actually something very special in the first place. The filmmakers would destroy the ant nest if they tried to film this in the wild,
一旦进去，毛虫就会做出非凡的事情。它们刺激一个内部器官，频率大约在 300 赫兹左右。我得查一下“Strygillate”这个词。它的意思是摩擦腿、翅膀或身体其他部位发出刺耳的声音。在这种情况下，这是毛虫试图模仿一只饥饿的蚁宝。这种声音会刺激蚂蚁去喂养毛虫。所以这是跨物种的交流，这在最初实际上是一件非常特殊的事情。如果他们试图在野外拍摄这个，电影制作人会毁掉蚁巢，
so they established a colony inside a film set and filled it with tiny periscope cameras. And to capture the sound, Chris Watson used what's called a particle velocity microphone, which can record extremely quiet sounds. And I have to go into a BBC radio studio, very, very, very quiet place. And I had a selection of these caterpillars, which are then placed on this particle velocity microphone about the size of a, imagine like a P,
于是在一个电影布景里建立了一个蚁群，并装满了微小的潜望镜摄像机。为了捕捉声音，克里斯·沃森使用了所谓的粒子速度麦克风，它可以录制极其安静的声音。我不得不去 BBC 的录音室，一个非常非常非常安静的地方。我有一小批这种毛虫，然后把它们放在这个粒子速度麦克风上，大小就像一个……想象一下像豌豆一样，
that sort of diameter, but it's flat. This animal was placed on top and eventually produced this vibration which I recorded. One of the most astonishing sounds and bits of behaviour that I've ever witnessed but it would have been impossible to record it under wild conditions, as indeed it was impossible to film the behavior under wild conditions. Both Chris Watson, the sound recordist and Richard Hinton, the fully artist, work to give us accurate and satisfying sounds, albeit in different ways.
那种直径，但它是平的。这只动物被放在上面，最终产生了这种振动，我把它录了下来。这是我见过的最令人惊叹的声音和行为片段之一，但在野外条件下录制是不可能的，正如在野外条件下拍摄这种行为是不可能的一样。无论是录音师克里斯·沃森还是拟音师理查德·Hinton，都在努力为我们提供准确且令人满意的声音，尽管方式不同。
But Watson says there's something inherently artificial in the process of making nature films. Native documentaries are not reality. It's the creation of an illusion like any other piece of entertainment. But a lot of viewers get upset when they find out that their favorite nature documentary isn't totally real. Richard Hinton, the foliartist, says he gets reactions like this all the time. You know, when I tell people what I do for a living, people are either fascinated or they want to punch me in the face. Don't punch Richard Hinton in the
但沃森说，制作自然电影的过程本身就带有人工的成分。自然纪录片不是现实。它就像任何其他娱乐作品一样，是幻觉的创造。但许多观众在发现自己最喜欢的自然纪录片并不完全真实时会感到沮丧。拟音师理查德·欣顿说他经常遇到这样的反应。你知道的，当我告诉别人我以什么为生时，人们要么着迷，要么想揍我一拳。别打理查德·欣顿。
face. I cannot stress this enough people. Discovering all the work that goes into the final product should not tarnish it. Nature documentaries are still movies, and they need a little movie magic, just like any other film. Chris Palmer, the filmmaker from the beginning of the story, says the most important thing is that the movie magic is being used to tell the truth. He actually thinks that renting wolves,
我怎么强调这一点都不为过，各位。发现幕后投入的所有工作不应该玷污最终的产品。自然纪录片仍然是电影，它们需要一点电影魔法，就像任何其他电影一样。故事开头的电影制作人克里斯·帕尔默说，最重要的是电影魔法被用来讲述真相。他实际上认为租用狼，
like he did to show viewers how they behave in their dens, was probably fine. Palmer says if he had to show viewers how they behave in their dens was probably fine. Palmer says if he had to do it over, he'd likely do it the same way, but make it clear to the audience somehow that the scene was not recorded in the wild. Palmer thinks a lot of documentary filmmakers are doing their best to bring us accurate representations of animals in the wild, but he does see one big problem. Even some of the best work out there fails to acknowledge human impacts on ecosystems. Which is giving the impression that we don't have any environmental challenges.
就像他为了向观众展示它们在巢穴中的行为所做的那样，可能并没有问题。帕尔默说，如果让他重来一次，他可能会用同样的方式去做，但会以某种方式向观众明确说明这个场景并不是在野外录制的。帕尔默认为，许多纪录片制作人都在尽最大努力为我们带来野生动物在野外的准确表现，但他确实看到了一个大问题。即使是其中一些最好的作品也没有承认人类对生态系统的影响。这给人一种我们没有任何环境挑战的印象。
Palmer says that a lot of nature documentaries these days show animals as if they live in some magical fantasy world, completely divorced from human civilization. There's no shots of the nearby city, or the coal mine that's encroaching on Habitat. You know, you watch the shows and you think there was nothing wrong with the world, nothing wrong. Which is its own form of deception. When you make a film about the natural world to omit any mention of the environmental challenges faced by that natural world is misleading.
帕尔默说，如今许多自然纪录片将动物表现得好像它们生活在某种神奇的幻想世界中，完全脱离了人类文明。没有附近城市的镜头，也没有侵蚀栖息地的煤矿。你知道，你看这些节目，你会认为世界上没有什么不对劲的，没有什么不对劲的。这本身就是一种欺骗。当你拍摄一部关于自然世界的电影时，忽略对该自然世界所面临环境挑战的任何提及是具有误导性的。
But Palmer still believes in the power of good filmmaking. He thinks that if we want to solve big environmental challenges like species extinction and climate change, we need compelling true stories about nature. And to tell a true story, sometimes you need a little fakery. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald with Sharif Yusuf, Delaney Hall, Avery Truffleman, and me Roman Mars. Katie Mingle is our senior editor Kurt Colstead, is the digital director and Terran Mazza is the Baroness. All the music was composed by Sean Rihon. We are a project of 91.7K, all W in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, in Vietaful, downtown, Oakland, California.
但帕尔默仍然相信优秀电影制作的力量。他认为，如果我们想解决物种灭绝和气候变化等巨大的环境挑战，我们需要引人入胜的关于自然的真实故事。为了讲述一个真实的故事，有时你需要一点虚假的手段。99% Invisible 本周由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，参与者还有谢里夫·尤وسف（Sharif Yusuf）、德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）和我罗曼·马尔斯。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是我们的资深编辑，库尔特·科尔施泰德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监，特兰·马扎（Terran Mazza）是女男爵。所有音乐均由肖恩·里洪（Sean Rihon）创作。我们是旧金山 91.7K、全 W 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽电台街的 Radio Row。
You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, I tweet at Roman Mars, the show tweets, at 99Pi or we're on Instagram and Tumblr too. But if you want to know what the word, Scarcatecter means, you have to go to 99pi.org. Radio TIPI from P-R-X. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并为其点赞，我在推特上是 @Roman Mars，节目的推特是 @99Pi，我们也在 Instagram 和 Tumblr 上。但如果你想知道“Scarcatecter”这个词是什么意思，你必须去 99pi.org。来自 PRX 的广播 TIPI。你本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子来留下评论。